en 1989 le réalisateur robert zemeckis
nous offrait un avant-goût fantaisiste
de ce que serait la vie avec michael j
fox dans le rôle de marty mcfly retour
vers le futur partie d'eux nous a fait
voyager dans le temps à bord de la
légendaire de lorien à destination du 21
octobre 2015
même sans gêne qui se passe
partiellement dans le futur c'est
surtout le regard des années 80 que
mâcon s'imaginait 2015
le festival spasm à montréal souligne la
date mythique évoqué dans le film lors
d'une soirée thématique recréant des
scènes qui ont marqué l'imaginaire d'une
génération entière les fautes voiture en
train de voler en ce moment il ya
toujours pas de revoir non plus
malheureusement c'était assez pâle est
prêt à payer tu te recommander des
répliques en ligne le film prédisaient
plusieurs innovations technologiques
dont certaines ont vu le jour il ya des
lunettes 3d le cinéma 3d pas son mondial
jazz 19 dans le film on est quand même
loin de l'espèce de utopique ex imaginé
dans le film parmi les gadgets qui
faisait rêver il y avait les chaussures
autour la sambre de marty mcfly
tout ce que je veux sur pepsi le
restaurant robotisée et bien d'autres
technologies qui font maintenant partie
dont l'échelle 18 24 satellites on
accroche sur le mur et les le le
multi-écran également on le voit et la
visioconférence est en fait partie
car je pense que justement ce qui fait
la force d'un bon auteur de
science-fiction c'est d'être capable de
nous faire un peu rêver avec ses
technologies loi qui n'existe pas encore
vraiment mais qu'on peut voir débarquer
plus vite on pense comme par exemple
l'écran tactile dans les années 80 on
était très très loin et ce n'est pas
terminé certaines avancées
technologiques proposées dans le film
commence à peine à être manufacturés
dont les lunettes de réalité virtuelle
et de réalité augmentée actuellement on
est en train de travailler par exemple
chez microsoft à une lunette qui
s'appelle la all all ends et une lunette
qui te laisse entrevoir le monde autour
de toi sauf que on lui en rajoute des
images juxtaposées à celle que tu voi et
alors que la compagnie lexus planche sur
son prototype durable board connaît-il
de la voiture volante de fer à fujia qui
travaille là dessus il ya une compagnie
cela vient également aéromobile il n'y a
pas dit aussi qu'il travaille sur un
prototype ça comme un peu un hélicoptère
sont gyrocoptère étonnamment le film
prédisait aussi la victoire des cubs le
21 octobre 2015 mais comme sont dans les
séries de la nature du baseball majeur
effectivement you ça on le saura dans
quelques semaines si on veut juste
retour vers le futur nous avions fait
rêver mais avait toutefois sous-estimé
la place qu'occuperait dans nos vies
internet nos cellulaires et les réseaux
sociaux
ici tamyras pointe radio canada montréal